[Música]
erika de juramento como alcalde de la
ciudad de nueva york en el centro de
manhattan y poco después de recibir el
año nuevo inició su mandato ante unas
15.000 personas es el segundo
afroamericano en ocupar el campo
francia asumió la presidencia de turno
del consejo de la unión europea y manuel
macro plantea una europa más soberana y
con un modelo económico sostenible
ambientalmente el puesto podrá
impulsarlo para las presidenciales de
abril
miles de partidarios de una alianza
iraquí de grupos armados conmemora en el
segundo aniversario del asesinato del
general qasem soleimani resultado de un
ataque con aviones no tripulados
estadounidenses el 3 de enero de 2020 el
líder de la fuerza quds era el brazo de
operaciones extranjeras de irán
muy buenas tardes para todos y
bienvenidos a una nueva actualización de
noticias en francés 24 yo soy daniel
hablando iniciamos en nueva york que
comenzó el 2022 con un nuevo alcalde
poco después de la ceremonia de año
nuevo en times square el demócrata eric
adams tomó posesión de su nuevo cargo su
principal reto es lidiar con la pandemia
de kobe de
1940 registrando récord de casos de en
su ciudad detalles en el siguiente
informe
eric adams
juro solemnemente que defenderé la
constitución
de un nuevo alcalde para los
neoyorquinos
sam's que lo vio jurar en plena
celebración de año nuevo con el objetivo
de sacar a la ciudad de la pandemia
nueva york que está lidiando actualmente
con un número récord de casos de kobe 19
impulsados por la variante omicron
y algunos dirán que necesitamos escoger
entre cerrar la ciudad y poner en
peligro a los neoyorquinos exponiéndolos
al hobbit yo digo no también a eso
estamos en 2022 no en 2020 con las
vacunas las pruebas y los tratamientos
tenemos las herramientas para vivir con
este virus y mantenernos sanos y todos
nos preocupamos por mantenernos seguros
nueva york ha tenido más de 40.000
positivos diarios de 19 últimamente
adams asegura que mantendrá un requisito
de vacuna para empleadores del sector
privado una medida implementada por su
predecesor bill de blasio y además
presentó su lineamiento de visión de la
ciudad picos de verse de esna gstaad
bout de un shopping porque una gran
ciudad no se trata sólo de hacer cosas
nuevas sino de hacer las cosas bien no
se trata de un espectáculo se trata de
estar presente es por eso que en mi tema
de mis 100 días es que staff on y he
formado un gobierno que solucionará el
problema de nueva york porque entiende
lo en un mallorquín os si antes este new
yok es este hombre de 61 años es hijo de
una limpiadora de casas y fue capitán de
la policía de la ciudad de nueva york
antes de dedicarse a la política se ha
descrito a sí mismo como el futuro del
partido demócrata otro de sus desafíos
son el desempleo de nueva york que se
acerca al 10% y los delitos violentos
que actualmente son más altos que antes
de la pandemia de kobe 19 y vamos a
américa latina en donde la movida
política está lejos de terminar en 2022
se definirá el rumbo electoral de varios
países de la región en colombia y brasil
los comicios estarán caracterizados por
fuertes pugnas entre la izquierda y la
derecha un panorama al que se le suman
todavía las inciertas elecciones en
haití
la movida política en suramérica podría
seguir con más sorpresas para el año
2022 en brasil el antiguo presidente
luiz inácio lula da silva anunció su
regreso a la campaña para los comicios
de este año con la intención de derrotar
al actual mandatario jair bolsonaro
he vuelto al juego pero jugar y quiero
ganar porque estoy seguro que puedo
mejorar la vida de las personas pero
rápido después este anuncio tuvo el
efecto de una bomba en el país según las
encuestas publicadas en noviembre por
genial cual es lula lidera la intención
de voto con el 48 por ciento mientras
que bolsonaro apenas alcanzaría el 21
por ciento en la primera vuelta esperada
el 3 de octubre de 2022 en colombia el
margen es más estrecho al no poder ser
reelegido el partido del actual
presidente iván duque el conservador
centro democrático ya encontró su
reemplazo óscar iván zuluaga frente a
ellos el rival de siempre gustavo petro
de izquierda y ex guerrillero del m-19
pero nosotros estamos contentos
realmente no es radical es una
democracia
no sé es que plantearse una democracia y
colombia es muy radical por ahora según
recientes encuestas de yanhaas el
favorito sería gustavo petro con 25 por
ciento de la intención de voto lejos del
4 por ciento del candidato del centro
democrático un margen que sólo podría
confirmarse en las urnas después de la
primera vuelta del 29 de mayo del 2022
las elecciones más inciertas por ahora
son las de haití después del asesinato
del presidente de jove en el móvil en
julio de 2021 y tras una elección
frustrada el primer ministro al nació
que se hará en los primeros meses de
y en noticias de europa alemania comenzó
hoy su periodo al frente de la
presidencia de turno del g7 una primera
tarea a gran escala para el nuevo
canciller germano olaf scholz a un mes
de haber llegado al cargo alemania asume
en reemplazo del reino unido- y con foco
en la pandemia la crisis climática y la
defensa del multilateralismo que hace
contrapeso a china y rúsia este último
país está fuera del bloque desde que en
2014 anexo a crimea a su territorio
y el presidente de francia en manuel
macrón ocupa a partir de este sábado la
presidencia rotativa de la unión europea
el mandatario afianza su liderazgo antes
de las elecciones de abril tras el
retiro de angra merkel como canciller
alemana y con la presidencia temporal
del consejo europeo macro en anunció una
agenda ambiciosa para el bloque de 27
países que podría servir para su campaña
de reelección en francia la última vez
que la nación estuvo al frente del
consejo europeo fue en 2008 con nicolas
sarkozy grupos de contención pueden
contar con mi total compromiso para que
este período que ocurre es sólo cada 13
años sea un tiempo de progreso una época
de avances hacia el control de nuestras
fronteras nuestra defensa la transición
climática la igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres la construcción de una nueva
alianza con el continente africano un
mejor marco de plataformas de internet y
la cultura en europa
de fondón alternet y los valores que
lleva consigo nuestra unión europea y
democracia equilibrio entre libertad y
solidaridad una cierta noción de
humanidad estoy convencido que nos
permitirá estar a la altura de los
desafíos de nuestro tiempo
y 400 migrantes desembarcaron en el
puerto de pozzallo en el sur de italia
tocaron tierra por fin en tras su
rescate la semana pasada por la
organización si watch según la agencia
de la onu para refugiados más de 66 mil
personas llegaron a italia por mar desde
el norte de áfrica y oriente medio en
2021 se cree que más de 1800 personas
han muerto al intentar cruzar el
mediterráneo para llegar a europa
en india fallecieron al menos 12
personas y otras docenas resultaron
heridas por una estampida en un
santuario hindú en cachemira la policía
informó que todos los heridos fueron
hospitalizados y se cree que la
emergencia ocurrió cuando una gran
multitud de devotos que habían venido
para marcar el comienzo del año nuevo
ingreso al templo
y miles de integrantes de un grupo
paramilitar chiíta respaldado por irán
salieron a las calles de bagdad para
conmemorar el segundo aniversario del
asesinato del general iraní qasem
soleimani tras un ataque estadounidense
en 2020 los manifestantes piden que la
soberanía nacional regrese a irak
[Música]
se niegan a olvidar la muerte del
general iraní kazem suleimán y miles de
partidarios del grupo paramilitar chiíta
hasan shavit se reunieron en bagdad para
conmemorar el asesinato de su alemán y
el líder iraquí a wood maría luján de
quienes perdieron la vida en el ataque
aéreo no tripulado de las fuerzas
armadas estadounidenses el 3 de enero de
2020 justicia por la sangre de los
mártires y la completa salida de las
fuerzas extranjeras en irak no aceptamos
nada menos no dejaremos de perseguir ese
objetivo y no dudamos las fuerzas
extranjeras deben salir completamente
del territorio iraquí debemos lograr la
completa soberanía nacional de irak
desde la invasión liderada por estados
unidos en 2003 que derrocó al dictador
suní saddam hussein el pueblo iraquí ha
pedido insistentemente que la presencia
extranjera en cualquiera de sus formas
se retire de su territorio este sábado
varias organizaciones de irak
respaldadas por teherán reunieron a sus
líderes chiíes en distintas ciudades
para enviar un mensaje claro a eeuu
bueno le decimos a los estadounidenses
que sólo unos ilusos si piensan que
matando a abu macd y al mojan dis ya
qasem soleimani le quitan la soberanía
de irak queremos decirles que eso es
completamente falso teherán por su parte
busca conservar su profunda influencia
en irak mientras mantiene tensas
negociaciones con las principales
potencias mundiales que buscan revivir
el acuerdo nuclear de irán de 2015
finalizamos este resumen informativo
pero los invitamos a que sigan con
nuestra programación
[Música]